si l'on parle souvent de l'engagement
politique comme d'un sacrifice ou d'une
labeur il ne faut pas oublier qu'il
s'agit également d'un métier qui payent
très bien chaque mois le président de la
république gagne quinze mille 204 euros
brut
une somme équivalente pour le premier
ministre lui qui tout de suite il n'y a
pas de quoi s'affoler
du côté des députés le salaire mensuel
s'élève à 10000 136 euros 9600 29 euros
pour un secrétaire d'état
ou encore 7000 240 euros pour un député
ou un sénateur
rien que cela un métier qui payent très
bien et pas simplement quand on le fait
car même retraités nos responsables
politiques continuent de toucher des
sommes importantes
un ancien président touche chaque mois
ci 1220 euros sans compter que s'il
décide de siéger au conseil
constitutionnel comme il en a le droit
c'est très tribution peut atteindre plus
de 13 mille cinq cents euros en plus par
mois c'est une chance qui nous a été
donné pour 77% des français les
responsables politiques sont trop payés
alors selon vous les politiques sont-ils
trop payés alors c'est vrai qu'on a tous
les chiffres merci catherine rambert
d'être avec nous déjà qu'on gagne le
président de la république
emmanuel macron il ya le ton des 15000
euros 15 milles 203 euros
c'est ça alors est ce que vous trouvez
que c'est trop pour le président parlait
non non non non évidemment on va à
chaque fois rétorqué que c'est de
l'argent public donc il faut faire
extrêmement attention à cet argent là
puisque c'est notre argent mais pour
autant le sait c'est beaucoup moins
qu'un cadre supérieur ou un peu moins
patron d'une grande entreprise du cac 40
g vous êtes le seul à dire oui raymond
aussi pour le président 15000 euros ou
toxines truc sinon je peux un global que
le président m'a déjà je peux faire rire
binetou fall israel is a global baisse
alors nous on va vous donner chez moi
l'affairé du béton d'après à l'origine
c'est beaucoup trop pour leur présence a
été baissé mais encore une fois encore
une fois il ya une notion d'exemplarité
chez désolé pour moi le président de la
république française devait être alizés
ridicule le salaire médian des français
dans les deux périodes
tous ensemble c'est ridicule tu n'as
absolument pas comparer le niveau de
responsabilité il regarde la vitesse à
laquelle ils disent tous ce qui est
scandaleux sur les politiques c'est
parce qu'il touche quand ils sont en
fonction c'est que une fois qu'ils ne
sont plus en fonction quasiment jusqu'à
la fin de leurs jours
ils touchent des sommes qui sont
importantes du coup et izon et ils ont
un personnel de fonction qui ne
devraient à mon avis plus la voir alors
qu'est ce qui a trait à vendre ailleurs
vous avez des infos le premier missile
touche combien
on s'amuse environ comme le président de
la république mais ce qui est
intéressant cette affaire ils sont pas
trop payer les présidents en france et
pour on peut faire un comparatif avec
les présidents et les sauver leur père
combes et le ghana européen déjà combien
gagnent angela merkel angela merkel et
gagne 29 1000 euros par mois non mais
jamais je suis la pécho salmela merkel
elle couche 129 euros par mois avant de
regretter un angleterre boris johnson
raclée premier ministre à son écurie et
chancelière mais ses lecteurs ce pouvoir
en 2000 euros par mois encore ils sont
tous bien au dessus mais on espère en
espagne c'est ce niveau-là à peu près
ils ont tous le même avantage que nous
alors aujourd'hui je vais venir justin
trudeau canada gagne 19 10 euros
à votre avis est-ce que poutine gagne
plus ou moins que macron la réponse je
sais que c'est moi après megan 10000
euros
les sedin nos jours oui après les idents
au monde le mieux payé
c'est donald trump away 30000 euros par
mois c'est le seul président qui a
refusé de toucher ses limites et il
n'est pas payé
oui c'est vrai qu'il est pas il est très
riche il a refusé de payer en revanche
qui coûte très cher pour donald trump
c'est de surveiller toutes ses
résidences qui appelle résidence
d'accord et coûtera cher est ce que vous
savez pour megan le pape le pape cogan
de losail ou pas vous savez combien
gagnait ce que cet organisme ne sait pas
alors ça c'est intéressant sur un char
mais non 00 voilà les politiques qu'ils
arrêtent parce que j'aille voir là des
chiffres fous catherine rambert après on
va voir raymond je pense qu'il va
réveiller tout le monde quand il va
entendre les charmes parce que ya pas
que ça allait aussi démis et des anciens
politiques qui font des conférences et
sa wii alors isabelle avait raison c'est
scandaleux quand il quitte le pouvoir
c'est qu'ils en effet continué d'être
payés à revenir aux conférences par les
tâches pas d'argent surtout de l'état
est touché notation de 6000 euros et
quelque part moi et puis quand il siège
au conseil constitutionnel et touche
autour de 13000 euros par mois ça ne
l'est mais surtout ce qui est plus
scandaleux c'est quand ils sont au
pouvoir ils ont la fibre sociale ils
veulent dégraisser l'état faire des
économies en revanche quand il le quitta
ils sont beaucoup moins d'accord et
profite à fond du système bien sûr un
homme pas un président qui quitte le
pouvoir il en appartement de fonction
une voiture de fonction
sept collaborateurs avis un président
très jeunes futurs et chauffeurs
justement le président maquereau a
refusé ces indemnités il a dit après la
première forêt sans histoire président
volontariat prénom il a déjà annoncé
qu'il rêvait d'être élu collaborateurs
deux gardes du corps et deux chauffeurs
avis et ils ont même des transports en
avion est en train gratuit non y'a juste
et hollande qui avait fait passer un
décret pendant qu'il était président
demandant que ce qui n a qu une
dégressivité dans tout cela parce que je
soutiens que valéry giscard d'estaing
dont on espère qu'il ira mieux parce
qu'il a des souhaits de santé ça fait 40
ans qu'ils aient pu commencer à rouler
dedans alors et sur les conférences
alors les présidents du vca prison il
est créé un vrai business donc au
pouvoir ils ont la fibre sociale après
ils font de l'argent
un des business des anciens présent ce
sont évidemment les conférences qui sont
payés pour une confiance c'est-à-dire un
ancien président va prendre françois
hollande françois hollande c'est pas le
mieux payé en euros 70 euros françois
hollande pour une conférence en est une
de mes frères moi je vais faire du
pédalo avec lui il m'a fait faire un
tour de scooters la dernière fois
nicolas sarkozy et touchent entre 75 et
200 mille euros à la petite affichette
dénonçant publiquement des scènes sur
nicolas sarkozy qui entend une confiance
tu peux lui donner 20 bars c'est une
boîte est là et c'est là c'est à prendre
ou à laisser le cas
d'accord mais s'il ya des gens qui lui
donne c'est vrai que c'est comme ça et
on attend ses voisins la scala public et
l'argent privé
attention c'est vrai qu'à plainte
politiques qui disent ils la phrase des
politiques c'est après la politique je
vais essayer de gagner de l'argent c'est
ce qu'ils disent un peu tout voilà
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est un peu c'est un débat un peu plus
jadis parce que franchement autant les
footballeurs autant de footballeurs
karim lamborghini s'entraînent une heure
et demie au parc des princes ou au
vélodrome
il repart chez lui où il va en boîte le
soir qui toutes deux millions par mois
c'est scandaleux pour tout le monde
autant d'hommes politiques personne ne
veut le faire c'est un boulot d'enfer
ibos 24 heures sur 24 et ce qu'ils
gagnent non mais attention je suis qui
gagnerait beaucoup plus si c'était dans
le privé était chef d'entreprise ou
patron d'un grand groupe
ils gagnent tout ils viennent y opus
dont sacerdoce c'est une volonté d'alors
remesurer ça ça aussi alors j'ai aussi
le salaire des mers parce que quand
madame le maire de votre ville vous qui
nous regardent et abattu vous dire c'est
selon le nombre d'habitants a passionné
mais en fait 500 habitants c'est 1991
euros par mois ça veut dire faut faire
venir des gars chez vous un mille
habitants 1167 veut dire un voile à 3520
vous pouvez regarder donc chez vous 2010
1000 habitants deux mille cent vingt
mille habitants de mille cinq cent
cinquante mille habitants 3500 moins de
100000 habitants 4200 plus de 100000
habitants 5600 et voilà et je vous le
dis donc ça veut dire que anne hidalgo a
gagné 5000 si son nom a pris man anne
hidalgo françois les pv et urbaines et
tous plus d'argent avec des différentes
fonctions qu'ils occupent à alors c'est
qu'on est motif que vous avez sur les
politiques parce que raymond là il est
énervé raymond pour toi mais je
rebondisse calais jean michel il faut
pas tomber dans le rouge à 10 en effet
ce qu'est un peu scandaleux à mon sens
c'est de toucher des deux côtés c'est à
dire quand on gagne beaucoup d'argent
dans des conférences pourquoi pas ils
ont une compétence dans tes présent mais
la décence serait de renoncer aux
avantages paie le fait ça parce que ils
les ont toujours les avantages des
zombies dégressivité métier minimes et
un ancien président français coûte deux
fois plus cher qu'un ancien président
américain maintenant vous rendez quoi ça
nous coûte 2 millions d'euros par an un
ancien pro américains dont quatre fois
plus cher maintenant s'abaisser coûte 1
8 million $ par an maintenant on espère
juste que donald trump bien vouloir
venir habiter en france
raymond bas j'ai noté le mot de jean
michel parce que je pousse jadis menadi
poujadiste ses valets real appareils de
chef d'entreprise vous avez pris le
problème à l'envers c'est mon avis je
parle que pour moi vous avez pris
preneur alors vous parlez de joueurs de
foot un joueur de foot il vient ici ils
payent des impôts en france
moi il fait plaisir parce qu'ils payent
des impôts en france et c'est une boîte
privée que le qatar pays des joueurs je
m'en fous ça me regarde pas ça me fait
baisser mais un poids mois
éventuellement valérie par deux chefs
d'entreprises un chef d'entreprise il
crée de l'emploi
il est là pour se défoncer il donne du
boulot des gens qui donnent dabou faire
des gens et ils payent des impôts en
france le chef d'entreprise
ce qui me dérange avec eux c'est que
vous avez parlé de 13500 euros/mois la
moyenne des français quand j'entends ces
mille 6000 8 c'est presque en un mois
ils prennent presque l'année des
français ça ça me dérange et ensuite il
faudra qu'ils payent le restaurant et ça
oui mais c'est ça la réalité et pas
quand tu entends je m'attends quand ils
se présentent qu'est ce qu'ils disent
quand ils présentent qu'est ce qu'ils
disent je veux le faire c'est mon projet
j'ai ma conviction c'est mes idées je le
faire pour la patrie je vais le faire
pour la nation et de l'aube se veut le
fer pour la patrie tu veux le faire pour
la nation prend 2000 banet
achète toi tu as volé des étudiants
il ya plein de gens qui gagnent un
médecin il fait 10 ans d'études plus que
ça non ahmed ça qui fait est bien fermée
à gals combien une infirmière gagne
combien le chauffeur livreur touche plus
qu'une infirmière je touche plus qui n'a
fermière on y promet palais bien sûr
alors moi je veux bien arriver mais je
veux bien alors je suis là ton message
et tout mais ces trucs là ont relevé les
petits salaires se cumulent les
conférences sur les conférences je m'en
fous qu'ils fassent des conférences et
de l'argent privé mais qu'on m'explique
un homme politique va prendre 20 mille
balles par mois et qui va avoir une
voiture et qui va avoir 7 mecs derrière
lui et qui va pas payer le restaurant
qui va pas payer l'avion pour lui et sa
famille qui va pas payer le train et que
les français si là il a dit ville sinon
personne à l'argile yoyo personnes des
carafes d'eau futur mais c'est pas
démago s'est passé j'étais banikoara
cgti je suis pas syndiqué on attendait
ces réseaux qui va être président de la
république
mais alors il lui qui va se passer en
métro avec un ticket restaurant pour
aller à la cantoche avec les autres non
mais faut pas déconner
non mais j'ai pas parlé du prisonnier
c'est usant ça sent déjà aussi oui tu
dises à 2001 député effectivement gagne
bien sa vie mais en même temps il a en
main en main et en charge des lois de la
france il reverse un peu ses
collaborateurs c'est très facile de dire
ils sont trop payés il faut pas parler
de collections allant des
responsabilités qui me disent ils font
pas ce qu'ils ont dit que c'est un autre
débat il faut parler avec son bad
company 2 balles par benjamin qui ne va
pas de conviction mois-ci d'auxi si je
veux que demain je me mens politique
pour aider mon pays pour sortir mon pays
de la mer pour relever mon pays je vais
pas aller dire donnez moi d'abord 20000
euros j'en ai rien à [ __ ] c'est gilles
explique une barre était pas besoin de
vingt mille euros pour bouffer tous les
jours pour que je comprends sa colère
parce que encore une fois qu'il faut ne
soit payer 15000 euros c'est pas énorme
pour un président en exercice je vois
pas du président enlève le si tu veut le
préserver de la housse est scandaleuse
c'est les abus tout pareil en france ou
dans sa prise en étau abuse de sa vie
même le conte le conjoint on enlève le
premier ministre ou sinon mais peut-être
qu'ils me voulaient un président peut
demander à avoir un
un appoint au président c'est scandaleux
donc c'est l'abus qui dérange et c'est
la boutique relax avec notre argent mais
ça fait 40 ans qui sont plus président
ça vous choisi sa douce et même quand
ils sont je suis en désaccord avec
benjamin jean michel même quand ils sont
en activité j'ai enquêté sur le sénat au
kenya les 7200 euros d'indemnités
prudentielles mais il ya 7500 euros pour
son équipe du sénateur en plus
et parfois il prend un membre de sa
famille 5900 euros de flyers
justificatives interdit et c'est moi
laissez moi il y avait huit mille euros
détraigne pour noël ça vient d'être
supprimée il ya les membres de la
famille qu'on la sécu la mutuelle
trente six mille euros de frais
d'obsèques après est ce qui déborde si
quand le sénateur décède ça ne coûte pas
trente six mille euros
on donne à sa famille quand il décède
une partie de sa retraite à sa femme 10%
à ses enfants
gratuité des transports 40 aller retour
par an en avion l'économie comme dans
l'ancienne urss
à québec c'est au tour de gauche cassée
wet ones base ici tu vas des l'abattoir
à vis de privilèges